I mean there's been lots of focus on the
Premier League but in many ways it's the
other leagues that are really going to
feel the brunt of the cope in nineteen
crisis what do you think should happen
in other leagues
yeah I think that the as you rightly say
a lot of focus has been understandably
on the top end of the pyramid but
actually it's the club's primarily now
in leagues one and two that faced a
difficult time because the real question
is that well the real the real issue is
that these clubs are like so much more
on gate income than the other clubs
further update up the pyramid and
there's some big questions as well about
what happens with the league's don't end
up being played I mean Tranmere Rovers
for example currently in a relegation
spot with a game on a hand would you
accept relegation not at this point in
time we the board put out a statement on
Thursday and we're seeking clarification
on a number of points and basically
what's the basis a decision what's the
timescale involved so we can properly
prepare our position the board did in
fact indicate that they there's a
strange phrase they used it didn't ask
for feedback they just wanted clubs to
basically think about the proposal that
they put together my assumption from
that is they prepared to take
submissions and in fact they both knew
and the Germans only knew that I was in
the process of putting together our
submission I think broadly what what
you're looking at is because and I
understand the difficulties you don't
actually have regulations to cover this
so broadly you either continue and play
out the season or alternatively avoid
the season or alternatively you make
some kind of change of the regulations
which requires a compromise because a
lot of the lower league clubs cannot
afford to continue playing at this point
in time whereas some other clubs want to
finish off and affect their sporting
chance so if you've got a chance of
promotion or if you've got a chance of
avoiding relegation and then you should
be allowed to do that
rather than having something imposed on
you which stops there it's really
difficult balancing out isn't it you
mentioned there the financial issues for
some of the clubs are on it in the
Premier League you may see the season
voided certainly it feels as if you know
in front of live audiences are a long
way off how difficult financially is
that going to be for many clubs well I
think this is the background contact to
the the what was suggested by the
leaders of framework on Thursday and
it's a very difficult one because I
actually personally believe that you
know we haven't seen the worst of it yet
and during the course for the summer you
will see a lot more financial stress on
the club's as we move forward and they
continue to pay wages we're just going
through the may way pay than they paid a
day as we speak and that I know has put
a lot of clubs under pressure and then
when I come to June as well then of
course it gets worse and worse and there
were attempts to try and negotiate with
the PFA and the players themselves as
regards their contribution to what I
call a cash hole but today I'm not
certain as to where that's got to
they've been some deferrals of payments
but the problem of course is that whilst
you may look at the the hole and it's
been articulated as two hundred million
to September I think it's bigger than
that I think you've got to add to that
deferred creditors which is not don't
think it's calculated and that figure
these where you've put off paying Pierre
ye etc and also advancing advances of
income so you know there is a real
financial Maelstrom coming towards the
league at this point in time and that's
one of the reasons why we are Amir do
not want to have what is a decision
foisted on us which is basically going
to affect us financially and
fundamentally when you come down to it
the reason to try and stop playing out
the league is based on a fundamental
decision so you know why do you do that
and then you know in terms of certain
clubs voiced on them an even worse
position yeah it's a really worrying
time when you consider how important so
many of these clubs are to their local
communities do you think that we could
see football clubs go into the wall
because of this yeah it's always very
difficult not to be sensational because
people pick up that comment and say you
know form achieve exact physics clubs
going to all I was an insolvency
practitioner and worked in Tehran and I
think what you'll see is that a lot of
clubs will sort of go down and stumbled
that road to insolvency you might see
people going getting high court orders
against them etc but the whole process
around that is delayed anyway so you
know that they'll they'll bumble on for
a period of time what I've spoken to the
AFL about none I'll ask the question
about two weeks ago as one of the ways
in which you prepare for the debacle
that's coming in the financial debacle
then you know have you looked at using
the administration and there were talks
about dealing with the insolvency
service to get what we call light
touching administration and that enables
basically I was going to use a technical
term debtor in possession but late and
that enables the management to continue
on because this is nobody's fault this
is a pandemic and if you do that if you
get lights which administration have
they worked up you know a panel of
insolvency practitioners that they can
trust and you know not to sort of
absolutely sort of charge it exorbitant
fees etc they're the types of things
that the FL should be doing now to
prefer for the eventualities that some
of the clubs may go into administration
and in addition to that looking at the
sporting sanctions that you introduce
because once again this isn't necessary
as a consequence of financial
mismanagement this is as a consequence
for the pandemic and therefore I think
they need to be considering that you
know clubs may need to go to the
protection of Administration which in
itself you know if you're in solvency
expect you know that that was brought in
on the basis of trying to help and help
clubs and well help companies so it is a
rescue procedure if applied and I think
it needs to be modified for the
circumstances of the pandemic